un sport planétaire et une finale suivie
dans plus de 200 pays
c'est ici qu'on trouve les racines du
basketball allemande en ontario petite
municipalité de 5000 habitants dans son
village natal une statue témoigne de
l'importance de l'inventeur de ce sport
le docteur james nesbitt le basket ball
a bien changé depuis ses débuts dit
bonnie macbeth mais le docteur nice me
serais heureux de sa version moderne
boni et l'arrière arrière arrière petite
nièce de james nesbitt giné smet a
grandi sur cette ferme dans les années
1870 ce avant d'aller étudier puis
enseigner à montréal à l'université
mcgill intégrité dur labeur travail
d'équipé c'est ici qu'il a appris ces
valeurs qu'il a voulu transmettre devenu
plus tard enseignants au massachusetts
james nesbitt a inventé le basketball
pour occuper ses élèves turbulents
pendant l'hiver au musée de la fondation
desmedt on retrouve une copie à noter à
la main des premières règles du
basket-ball tel que joué pour la
première fois en décembre 1891 au
massachusetts
à l'époque il était interdit de dribbler
ce qui aurait été impossible avec ce
ballon de cuir ovale garni de lassay
mais ce qui a le plus changé ce sont les
paniers les filets d'aujourd'hui était à
l'époque de vrai panier de pêche n'ont
trouvé le concierge qui travaillait avec
le docteur nessma éventuellement décider
de couper le fond des paniers
l'histoire du père du basketball fascine
les curieux d'autant plus que les
projecteurs sont braqués sur le sport
grâce aux capteurs
on connaissait l'histoire des paniers de
pêche mais on ne savait pas que jean
genet smit et est originaire d'ici à
demain sur touristes le basket ball a
changé la vie de beaucoup de jeunes
défavorisés affirme-t-elle le docteur
nesmy en serait comblé il a toujours été
humble et fier de ses origines modestes
on n'aime pas c'est ici que james
nesbitt serait un fier partisan des
raptors ici philippe leblanc radio
canada remonte en ontario